SPEAKER: Let's take a quick
look at how to use Google Cloud
SQL on the command line.
Go to cloud.google.com and
open up your Cloud console.
Go to the SQL section.
Here you can see your
Cloud SQL instances.
If you don't have a Cloud SQL
instance you can create one.
Click your instance to be taken
to the Instance Overview page.
Now go to the Access Control tab
and then go to the Users tab.
Specify a new root password.
If you don't have the
Google Cloud SDK installed
on your computer, see the
link in the description
for how to install it.
Now open your command
line and type gcloud beta
SQL connect, the name of
your instance, and then
the username root.
Type in your password
and you'll be
greeted with the familiar
mySQL command line.